let's have a look at our solutions over
here I've asked you to solve for X a
couple of different times in a couple of
different ways the first one is just an
equation this is kind of what we're used
to seeing okay
now excuse me have a look at the first
line can you tell me what's happened to
both sides on the first line can you
tell me what operation has happened yagi
okay fantastic both sides have been
divided by five and I didn't tell you to
do that but you sort of could think and
reason through that that's a good idea
because why what would make you think to
do that
so you knew okay where I'm going is to
get that X on its own well the first
thing you got to do is get x squared on
its own and that's why truly area is
nothing else you can really do but the
reason why is for that purpose to to
isolate X now from the second to the
third line x equals four we talked about
this before that you can know whether a
solution is right by testing it yeah by
substituting it in is x equals four a
solution it is because 5 times 4 squared
equals 80 okay
thumbs up okay however however and I'd
love you all to write this underneath
the question or beside the question for
me okay a bit of a warning we haven't
talked about this much before because we
haven't encountered situations where
it's been relevant but substitutions can
confirm answers but it isn't
comprehensive I'll explain what that
means once I finish writing it
yes sort of so the idea is x equals four
I can use substitution to find out
whether that was thumbs up or thumbs
down okay because if I'm I tried it out
and I didn't get a T then great I know
it's not a solution I'll have to try
something else but as I know is
suggesting it doesn't give you as much
insight into the question because it
doesn't tell you whether you've got all
the answers that's what comprehensive
means right comprehensive schools take
all students and a comprehensive answer
includes not just an answer but all the
answers there's actually one other one
has anyone got it yeah Arian okay so in
addition to plus four we also want minus
four and the shorthand way we have to
write that is just to put that plus
minus sign at the front okay and when
you think about it you can see why
negative four can also be substituted in
it also works both of them are solutions
to this okay so watch out that's an easy
thing to forget that's why we had a look
at it just now something similar is
happening down here now have a look
here's our here's some working here I
love that there's some lines of working
to show us what's going on the first
question I have is just the first line
what does it mean what's going on
somebody hasn't said anything yet want
to make a suggestion why on earth would
we write 10 equals x squared plus one
where's it come from anyway yeah is
about very good so x squared plus 1 we
recognize it's the equation of this
parabola now when you have a look at the
equation y is equal to x squared plus 1
but I know at this particular spot that
Y should be 10 does that make sense
yeah so instead of writing y equals x
squared plus 1 I write 10 equals x
squared plus 1 so that's why we write
this first line looks great okay then we
get to this line what do we do to both
sides we just subtract 1 everything's
looking sweet but then we come up
against the similar issue as we did in
the first question that's why these go
together okay
of X equals three is it a solution to
these equations
hmm now this is a bit sneaky I admit
this is one of the other reasons I gave
you two questions that is three there's
a bit of a curveball in here x equals
three is the solution to these equations
but it's not a solution to my diagram
because have a look where is x equals
three where is it it's on the it's on
the right-hand side right so it's over
here okay
x equals three would be this guy okay as
the consequence when you look at the
diagram you're like oh wait this guy
should give me two solutions just like
here I would say plus or minus three but
and in fact I'm probably none of you
wrote it this way because I've never
really shown you a question like this
before
underneath Q please right after plus or
minus three X is less than zero because
look at Samba it's on the left hand side
I'm going to say that from the diagram
I'll say that again just so you
understand what I'm told is the point
has been drawn on the left hand side so
whatever X is it has to be negative like
all these guys over here x equals minus
1 minus 2 minus 3 minus 100 etc okay
so therefore the diagram tells me that X
must be negative so I can do this thing
which is called disregarding a solution
x equals 3 with a solution that came out
but I put it to one side I disregard it
because it doesn't make sense from the
picture we were provided does that make
sense
so so this is exactly how I would write
it and I think writing the word only
emphasizes the fact that you've um
you've taken one with solutions away
okay so I encourage you to do so it's
just clear a communication okay